Sarah is in Rhode Island hi Sarah
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hi Dave
thanks for taking my call today sure so
I'm calling because my church is looking
to build an addition onto the side of
our church building and they're looking
at possibly getting mortgage for it and
we do have enough money in the bank to
cover it but they want to split half
mortgage and half paying it straight up
in order to make people who are more
comfortable about having money in the
bank how do I convince them to not go
the way of debt and how can I also help
encourage people to give more as well
because they're not for having a pull
money out of our investments every year
in order to make our annual budget how
many people in the church we have about
80 somewhere between 80 and 100 that
regularly attendance and what is your
position in the church I'm the
administrative assistant to the pastor
as well as a clerk and just a member as
well okay so do you think you'll be
listened to I think you would be
probably but are you a person do you do
you think you're a person with
credibility that they would listen to I
certainly hope so
part of my concern is that I've grown up
around a lot of these people I'm 28 a
lot of them have known me since I was
literally a baby so I'm worried that
some of them will see me as a child
maybe not intentionally but to some
degree yeah you have to they have to
have worked around you since you were 14
and not you know if they've worked
around you lately
you're obviously articulate you've you
know you the way you presented this was
very clear and very objective and so you
know you're carrying your weight I can
tell that but if they hadn't been around
you they might not see that so that
could be a problem okay that's a good
answer
well there's a couple things what kind
of church what brand where someone say
Baptist
it's basically your normal Baptist so we
go to church on Saturday and said 1508
Sabbath stuff well most of the time when
I hear
version of Baptist I hear
bible-believing evangelical am i right
exactly yeah okay yeah all right then
that's a lens we can use to make it to
have a discussion
okay here's what Larry Burkett used to
say a hundred years ago it feels like
now when I first heard him he said that
oftentimes the influencers in the church
the elders the Deacons of people sitting
on the church board are men and women in
business and the church board sometimes
looks like the Chamber of Commerce and
so it's a car dealer a whole life agent
a banker and the guy that owns a
hardware store and they all were in
businesses and so the pastor who's a
little bit intimidated by business
listens to the business people and they
make business decisions for the church
through the lens of a business not
through the lens of Scripture and that's
a mistake and so I would warn against
that that you don't make you know I
actually sat on a church board one time
and had a guy look at me and yell at me
across the table well I'm a banker I
know money and I looked at the pastor
and I said and he's the pastor and he
knows the Bible which is why we're here
by the way banker boy and so that
meeting didn't go well but uh anyway
this is why I don't serve on boards but
because I'm always right but you don't
want to do that okay but what the
approach I would use is say pastor I
think is really important that youth you
pray about this and think about how
we're making this decision and I know
that you would never make a decision
that wasn't biblical right and I think
you're gonna have a hard time finding
borrowed money in the Bible ever
mentioned positively it's not there
every time borrowed money is mentioned
in the Bible you're a fool you're a
slave
it's a curse oh no man any nothing but a
debt of love
even Romans or some argument as whether
that actually means that but it just
means relational debt but but either way
every time the word or the concept debt
is mentioned all through scripture it's
negative right so all the biblical
indicators are don't do it and pastor
you don't do things you don't preach a
sermon to make people feel good you
preach a sermon to help people align
their lives with the truth of Scripture
and sometimes that feels good and
sometimes it's a little bit of an out
sheet if God is telling us to build this
he will give us the money oh wait a
minute he already did right so we felt
my cash we should pay cash yeah
and 80 80 people don't need to be in bed
right right I had brought up to him the
potential of meetings FPU about a year
ago and I couldn't quite nail him down
on the yes sir right now so how can I go
about well there's a reason he does not
want that information spread around
there because that'll make these
decisions ridiculously hard right right
yeah it's hard for it's hard for a
church to have the whole church go
through FPU and then turn around to a
building program and going debt it's
very difficult instead what happens is
actually if you take the whole
congregation through giving will go up
because people will get out of debt and
get on a budget and when they get out of
that budget they're giving goes up
because people that love Jesus don't
it's not that they don't give because
they don't want to it's cuz they don't
mean money broke people just don't give
it's a simple equation right and so
anyway yeah you can try that and again I
think it's going to have a lot to do
with whether you or Bank or bob has more
influence with pastors ear there that's
what it's going to come down to but
biblically speaking you cannot proof
text this you cannot come up with a
Bible reason that this is okay there's
not one
I've been doing this 30 years and I get
hate mail all the time and people trying
to prove it and no one's ever been able
to find a single verse in all of
Scripture there's 2,600 verses in
scripture dealing with money and
possessions and 100 percent of the debt
references are negative there's not even
one you can make a case with and you
can't even go back and say well
culturally you can't even you just can't
do it I mean you've just got to go okay
we do not we're not evangelicals we
don't believe the Bible in its literal
form that's what you just have to go and
say that and if you say that then you
can just do about anything you want to
do then and so that allows you to go
wherever you want to go and that's what
people do sometimes and I understand
that but no no that's um that's how I
would approach it and I will tell you
that in my history and churches as a
church member or as a board member or
one of the leaders in the lay leaders in
the church I have had this conversation
and it's sometimes productive and it's
sometimes not and so it's just the thing
is be gentle and kind and don't cause a
big Rowell
don't cause big problems all that kind
of stuff you know just sit down and you
know be be done don't damage
relationships for the next 20 years
based on one conversation like I did
with old banker Bob there that didn't
they didn't go well and he's still done
like me and I kind of understand so I
get it
well basically I tell people not to do
what he does every day so it's okay